- [Interviewer] All right, Samantha.
Samantha, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from, originally?
- [Samantha] Here.
- [Interviewer] Right here in a...
This is Leslie County?
- [Samantha] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And this
is Hell for Certain Road?
- [Samantha] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Hell for Certain Creek,
I guess you'd call it.
You grew up with both your parents?
- No.
- [Interviewer] Who raised you?
- My mom, her and my dad got
divorced when I was about six.
And he, well, last time I talked to him,
I just turned eight and I'm 32 now.
I ain't heard from him since.
- [Interviewer] So you were raised by?
- Well, my aunts, my grandma.
- [Interviewer] And how would
you describe your childhood?
- It was pretty good.
Grew up with my cousins.
- [Interviewer] And how
far did you go to school?
- I graduated and I
done a year of college.
- [Interviewer] Oh, good for you.
And do you have children of your own?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How many kids you got?
- I got one little boy.
- [Interviewer] Are you married?
- No.
- [Interviewer] No.
So you're raising them on your own?
- Well, that's...
My mom's actually got custody of him
'cause I got a medical problem
and I'm not supposed to be left by myself.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Yeah, I take medicine for it.
- [Interviewer] What
condition do you have?
- Well, I was born having seizures.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- And then after I had
my baby, it was like
they just started back.
And...
- [Interviewer] So if you have a seizure
then the child is on its own and...
- Well, my mom and my
grandma try to make sure
somebody around me all the time.
'Cause I ain't supposed to
be left by myself and...
I take medicine for it.
- [Interviewer] So have you
ever left this part of Kentucky?
You ever been to Tennessee
or North Carolina?
- I've been to Tennessee and
I've been to...
Let's see, I've been to Ohio.
I got stuck in Indiana one time
for about three weeks
and I about took off
walking back to the house.
And I've been to Pennsylvania
but that's as far as
I've been away from home.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Are you happy here?
- Yeah
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Do you ever wonder what it'd
be like to live in a big city
or somewhere else?
Never.
What would you, I mean,
this is a rough way of living.
You're out in the mountains,
there aren't any stores nearby.
You're kind of isolated here
in the mountains.
What are the upsides and
downsides of living in
in a deep, this is a holler,
I guess you'd call it?
- Well in the winter time
you can't get out of here.
If it comes to real bad snow,
you're either walking or you're stuck.
And our lights, they go off,
well, they went off couple weeks ago,
I think it stayed off all
day, about half an hour,
before they finally come back down.
- [Interviewer] So no electricity?
But you have running
water here and you have...
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How do you heat?
- We use a gas stove or a kerosine heater.
- [Interviewer] And you've
had jobs before or no?
- I worked when I was in high school,
my sophomore year, they put me on...
my mom helped me get
on some kind of program
that you go through school.
And I worked at a little store
on that program all the
way up until I graduated.
And then I worked at
Kmart for a little bit
until they closed down.
But other than that, I ain't.
- [Interviewer] Did you have dreams
of doing something when
you were a little girl?
- I got a habit of...
I write a lot
and I was wanting to send
one of them off but...
I called this some kind
of publishing thing
they been showing on TV.
And a guy asked me my address
and I told him, he thought I
was lying and hung up on me.
- [Interviewer] 'Cause your address
is Hell for Certain Road?
- And I've been trying to get through that
but everywhere I call
like they think I'm
lying and hang up on me.
- [Interviewer] So do you
find people will judge you
kind of because of your accent?
Have you had people do this?
- Well, I used to get on dating sites,
and they'd asked you your age and all that
and your location.
Well, most of the time when I
tell him I was from Kentucky,
automatically they'd ask me
some of the dumbest questions there was.
- [Interviewer] Like what?
- Well, automatically
thought I was incest.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- I've had them as me
is my daddy my uncle.
And I don't know what all.
I've had people asked me...
And then sometimes when they found out
that I got a child and I'm not married
I've had someone say
some pretty bad things to me about that.
Which around here,
that's what I tell them,
I say about everybody
around here is gay, young
and aint married to their daddy or mommy.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, and
then your accent, did they,
did you get...
- I used to go to Indiana.
First, I rolled up
with my ex who stayed
with his grandma.
(clears thought)
And a bunch of her friends come over.
Well, I saw her saying something to him.
Well, they started
laughing and then they come
over and started telling me,
I will say this, say this.
And every time say it, they start laughing
[Interviewer] Because of your accent?
- They said you do a talk funny
I said you talk funny to me.
I said, you talk too proper
- [Interviewer] well, it goes both ways.
- Every one of them don't be like, yeah
I don't want to snipe from CD.
- [Interviewer] And does
that hurt your confidence
in terms of like maybe
moving to another place?
No, that's good.
- I ain't really thought
about moving or...
- [Interviewer] Do you have any regrets
about choosing to stay here
and the life you've chosen for yourself?
- [Samantha] Nah, I've thought
about leaving a couple times, but.
- [Interviewer] Would you
describe yourself as happy?
- [Samantha] Yeah
- [Interviewer] Do you ever get depressed
or anxious or angry or anything like that?
- [Samantha] Yeah, I
got an anxiety problem.
- [Interviewer] This is a,
it's a difficult life here.
Yeah.
- [Samantha] Can be sometimes when you...
- [Interviewer] what are the,
what are the hardest parts of living here?
You go into a store is difficult, right?
- [Samantha] Sometimes you
can't hardly get a ride.
If you, you buy at the
pace, it might take years
when your vehicle's towed up or.
I don't hardly go anywhere, and
- [Interviewer] I mean, poverty is kind of
every household is struggling to survive.
- [Samantha] The lights.
Got it.
And all that virus going
around, you can't do nothing.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. But,
but typically you, you survive
on how much a year or a month?
- [Samantha] Well, I live with my mom.
I don't.
- [Interviewer] So between, between your
you get assistance from the government?
- No, I'm trying to sign up on my check.
And I'm kinda having
difficulties with that.
- [Interviewer] And raising your child
makes it even more difficult.
Well, he draws one.
- [Interviewer] Oh, I see.
And you know, drugs are a big thing
for a lot of young people here.
Is that something that's
you've been involved in?
- No.
- [Interviewer] You stayed away from that?
- No. I've seen,
a lot of my friends.
It hurts, really.
Two good friends of mine
on counter drugs, and
- [Interviewer] They died?
Yeah.
Of the people that you
went to high school with.
How many other stayed,
have stayed here?
- I don't know.
I've been out of school so long.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
But do you have good friends here?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Amongst people
your age in this community,
how many are involved
in drugs, do you think?
- I don't know.
But the only people I
mess with is my family.
I don't,
which better by around.
There's keen on one another, so.
But all there is around his family.
- [Interviewer] Everyone's
related to somebody
in one way or another.
What do you, what do you think
of the future of this, this region?
Yeah, because coal mines
are kind of are fading away
and drugs have kind of taken over.
What do you think the future
for the younger generation is?
- I'd say by the time
my little boy gets up
in like high school.
I'd say it's going to be worse
because so much stuff they
coming out with nowadays.
- [Interviewer] But like,
if you wanted to go...
there's no movie theaters,
there's no bowling alleys,
there's no shopping
malls, there's nothing.
- Well, there's a couple of
stores in town over in hiding.
But around here, the closest store
around here is on Bald Fork.
I ain't really know where
around here to go to,
well unless you go for a riding or.
- [Interviewer] It's a
very simple way of living.
Yeah. There's no cell service here.
There's no technology that
- Well, we got internet,
but it's like I said it goes in and out.
It don't pick up too good
but one day you can have it real good.
And then one day it won't
even come on for you.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
But do you feel like you're
you're living the life that
you wish you would live?
You're happy here?
No regrets?
- No.
- [Interviewer] No?
What would you say is the most
important lesson you've
learned in your 30 years?
- [Samantha] I don't know.
- [Interviewer] All right.
Well Samantha,
thank you so much for sharing your story.
Good luck with your child.
And I hope you stay warm all winter.
- It's going to be hard around here
when it gets cold, you.
(chuckles)
- [Interviewer] You get stuff.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] All right.
Samantha, thank you so much.
- [Samantha] You welcome.
- [Interviewer] All right.